[Musica]
Chi l'avrebbe mai detto chi avrebbe mai
detto che quella sensibilità ambientale
così cresciuta negli ultimi anni dei
cittadini dei consumatori che ci ha
portato anche qui questa sera sarebbe
diventato un problema un problema per
l'ambiente ma come hai potuto succedere
semplicissimo l'ha cresciuta sensibilità
dei consumatori dei cittadini ha spinto
le imprese ad intravedere nel Tema
ambientale un'opportunità competitiva e
le imprese hanno cominciato a parlare
tanto di ambiente Quando un prodotto è
accompagnato da un asserzione che ne
qualifica le prestazioni ambientali e
quella sezione è falsa chi lo acquista
in base alla propria sensibilità
ambientale sta facendo del male
all'ambiente sta generando un danno un
vero paradosso
Beh intanto cerchiamo di capire
sta accadendo questo fenomeno
effettivamente
Beh insomma le affermazioni
ambientali sui prodotti negli ultimi
anni stanno crescendo molto
significativamente Guardate quelle
percentuali incredibili 73% di Termini
che riguardano la plastica e che
accompagnano alla pubblicità dei
prodotti 66% in riciclo è sicuramente un
tema di moda però attenzione è un tema
di moda attraverso cui le aziende
cercano di vendere i propri prodotti
soprattutto i prodotti più nuovi più
innovativi ovvero quei prodotti che
vengono immessi sul mercato e che
vengono Presentati al consumatore in
base alle proprie caratteristiche
ambientali Guardate semplicemente questa
ricostruzione fatta da quel consorzio
che gestisce il codice a barre e che
quindi ha visibilità su quello che va a
finire sul Packaging dei nostri prodotti
quelli che troviamo al supermercato su
questi prodotti vengono accompagnati da
rivendicazioni che vogliono vantare
qualità ambientali ormai con percentuali
veramente molto significative pensate
più di un prodotto su quattro si
presenta sul mercato facendo appello al
consumatore perché venga scelto Sulla
base del fatto che il consumatore è
sensibile all'ambiente Beh tutto questo
dovrebbe essere un bene Effettivamente
e lo è se non fosse che la nostra vita
ha cominciato ad essere quotidianamente
circondata da una pressione
straordinaria di claim che riguardano
l'ambiente tutti i prodotti che
scendiamo al supermercato
rivendicano in qualche modo un vantaggio
rispetto agli altri e non tutti questi
vantaggi potrebbero essere giustificati
effettivamente anche quelli che hanno
diciamo sono accompagnati da più buon
senso per esempio un prodotto che riduce
la plastica meno 75% di plastica nel
Packaging ci viene automatico
considerarlo una cosa buona per
l'ambiente potrebbe non essere vero
dipende da Qual è il materiale
alternativo che si potrebbe usare o che
veniva utilizzato per quel Packaging un
prodotto vegano un prodotto molto di
moda Beh vi assicuro che molti prodotti
vegani possono avere un impatto
sull'ambiente perché sappiamo che il
vegano vuol dire altro possono avere un
impatto sull'ambiente peggiore rispetto
a quello tradizionale E allora che cosa
sta succedendo e sta succedendo che
effettivamente
le diciamo
affermazioni che accompagnano i prodotti
sono in qualche modo
riconducibili a Termini ingannevoli per
il consumatore che cosa vuol dire
termini ingannevoli per il consumatore
vuol dire termini che
inducono il consumatore a scegliere quel
prodotto che sullo scaffale in realtà ha
un impatto ambientale peggiore Quanti
sono questi prodotti sul mercato ma le
indagini che noi abbiamo fatto in
università al Sant'Anna di Pisa con un
team specializzato su queste tematiche
ci dicono che questi claim possono
essere fino al 84% dei claim che
accompagnano i prodotti che noi troviamo
sul mercato o nelle pubblicità vuol dire
che 84 pubblicità su 100 presentano
caratteristiche che secondo i crismi
della trasparenza nei confronti del
consumatore sono ingannevoli sono claim
che vi inducono a scegliere il prodotto
sbagliato se Voi comprate quel prodotto
state facendo peggio per l'ambiente
rispetto a quanto l'azienda vorrebbe
convincervi a fare
84% è tanto è un diciamo una percentuale
che preoccupa se si traduce in carenze
informative significative Che tipo di
carenze stiamo riscontrando Beh intanto
carenze che riguardano gli aspetti
ambientali molte pubblicità ci parlano
di aspetti ambientali che non sono
rilevanti per il prodotto se io vi parlo
di un prodotto che non contiene plastica
ma quel prodotto è una bottiglia di
vetro è ovvio se io vi dico che un
prodotto cosmetico non è testato sugli
animali sto dicendo una cosa irrilevante
Perché Perché i test sugli animali sono
vietati per legge Quindi nessun prodotto
cosmetico è testato sugli animali Questi
elementi danno un quadro che viene
diciamo preso a riferimento per
identificare le pratiche di greenwashing
le pratiche di rinwashi non sono
soltanto quelle pratiche che diciamo
raccontano in malafede al consumatore
una cosa falsa per ingannarlo molte
pratiche di greenwashing sono
semplicemente dovute alla Inco
consapevolezza da parte del produttore
della completa informazione rispetto
alle performance del prodotto quindi il
produttore può parlare per esempio di
del fatto che l'auto è elettrica per
toccare un tema di moda Ma se c'è
carenza di informazione al consumatore
non viene detto l'elettricità Che
alimenta quell'auto Da dove proviene Da
dove proviene il consumatore non è in
grado di stabilire se quell'auto
Veramente meno inquinante delle auto
tradizionali perché quelle elettricità
potrebbe venire da termoelettrico E vi
assicuro che in quel caso un'analisi
scientifica
rivelerebbe che l'auto elettrica
potrebbe essere almeno tanto inquinante
come l'auto tradizionale oppure mancanza
di prove si fa un gran parlare di
biocarburanti Ma se la provenienza della
biomassa da cui viene derivato il
biocarburante non è certificata
Beh quella biomassa può essere coltivata
appositamente per produrre il
biocarburante e in quel caso i nostri
studi scientifici ci dimostrano che il
biocarburante Ha un impatto ambientale
che è paragonabile con quello dei
carburanti tradizionali
E allora che come si può fare per
risolvere il problema Come spesso accade
ed è stato già citato quando si parla di
fake news l'unico modo per combattere le
fake news e usare la scienza e in questo
caso gli strumenti li abbiamo sono
strumenti scientifici che portano il
consumatore a consultare impatti
ambientali e informazioni che riguardano
gli impatti ambientali dei prodotti per
scegliere quelli Meno impattanti o più
Green Come si direbbe Per esempio un
metodo è quello che dice Bisogna
considerare tutte le fasi del ciclo di
vita di un prodotto non si può
considerare soltanto se si apre il frigo
si vuole fare una merenda molto amica
dell'ambiente si trova una pesca si
trovano yogurt prendo la pesca perché
Orientativamente non ha Packaging non è
stata trattata industrialmente non è
stata prodotta in uno stabilimento
produttivo è stata accolta dall'albero
Attenzione però se non si considerano le
fasi di trasporto e gli impatti
ambientali del trasporto e si vuole
mangiare la frutta fuori stagione è
possibile che gli impatti ambientali del
trasporto siano talmente elevati perché
quel frutto proviene da talmente lontano
che addirittura il suo impatto
ambientale è peggio dello yogurt Quindi
prima considerazione tutte le fasi
seconda considerazione tutte le
problematiche ambientali se io vi dico
che una lavastoviglie è Green perché
consuma poca acqua attenzione perché una
lavastoviglie potrebbe consumare molta
poca acqua ma tantissima energia energia
è una delle cause principali
dell'effetto serra l'equilibrio tra le
due problematiche ambientali se ne
considera soltanto uno potrebbe essere
molto falsato in terzo luogo
considerazioni delle certificazioni le
certificazioni di parte terza da parte
di soggetti che nulla c'entrano nel
rapporto di compravendita tra l'azienda
e il consumatore possono dare garanzie
di parte terza che effettivamente un
prodotto abbia delle caratteristiche
ambientali migliori abbiamo a
disposizione Questi strumenti Beh
sicuramente oggi cominciamo ad averli Ci
sono casi eccellenti come questo che vi
mostrano in cui un'azienda ha dimostrato
che la propria soluzione spillare la
birra da un fusto di plastica che
sembrerebbe una cosa
straordinariamente negativa in realtà è
meno impattante del fusto di acciaio
perché per il per spillare la birra dal
fusto di acciaio bisogna usare tanta CO2
come gas propellente e soprattutto nel
futuro ci saranno strumenti come il
Digital product password che avete
sentito nominare che effettivamente
aiuteranno il consumatore ad informarsi
Qual è il mio suggerimento per il futuro
la raccolta di informazioni attraverso
Questi strumenti attraverso un QR Code
attraverso la lettura di informazioni
ulteriori in garantito in un link che
sul prodotto possano darvi maggiori
garanzie aiuta a mandare un messaggio
straordinariamente efficace alle aziende
di esigenza di correttezza esigenza di
informazioni solide robuste
scientificamente fondate per poter far
sì che la scelta del consumatore sia
informata consapevole e possa produrre
effettivamente dei benefici per
l'ambiente le aziende devono capire che
tingersi di verde non basta più Grazie
[Applauso]